JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about the divergence theorem,
also known as Gauss's
theorem, and flux,
and all that good stuff.
So I have a nice exercise
on it for you here.
So what I want-- so
I want you to take F,
and I want it to be the
field whose components are
x over rho cubed, y over rho
cubed, and z over rho cubed.
So here, rho is your usual rho
from spherical coordinates.
Rho is equal to the
square root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
And I want S to be the
surface of the box whose
vertices are plus or
minus 2, plus or minus 2,
plus or minus 2.
So it's a cubical box.
So what I'd like you to
do is, first in part a,
I'd like you to show
that the divergence of F
is 0, wherever the
field F is defined.
In part b, what I'd
like you to think about
is whether we can
conclude from that,
that the flux through the
surface of S is equal to 0.
All right.
And in part c, what
I'd like you to do
is to use the extended
version of Gauss's theorem--
or the extended version of
the divergence theorem--
in order to actually
compute the flux through S
by computing an integral.
So why don't you pause the
video for a couple of minutes,
work out this
problem, come back,
and we can work it out together.
Hopefully you had some
luck with this problem.
Let's get started.
Part a asks you to compute
the divergence of F.
So in order to
compute that, we're
going to need to take
the partial derivatives
of the components of F. And in
order to do that, at some point
I'm going to need to take a
partial derivative of rho.
So let me first compute the
partial derivatives of rho,
and that will save me a
tiny bit of work later.
So rho is equal to the
square root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
So partial rho partial
x-- well, you just
apply your usual
chain rule here.
And I guess we get
a half, but then we
get a 2 that cancels
it, so I think
this works out to x divided by
the square root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared,
so that's x divided by rho.
All right.
And I'm just going to
keep rho around here,
because otherwise I have to
write out the square root of x
squared plus y squared plus z
squared over and over again,
and this is going to
save me some effort
and would save you
some effort as well.
So OK.
So this is rho.
So this is d rho dx.
So we want to take the x partial
of the first component of F. So
that's the x partial
of x over rho cubed.
OK.
And you just apply your
usual quotient rule,
so what do we get?
We get the derivative
of the top.
So that's rho cubed
minus-- OK, so the top
is x times the derivative
of the bottom, which
is going to be 3 rho
squared times x over rho--
so that's 3-- so we
have an x-- so it's
3 x squared rho, divided
by the bottom squared,
which is rho to the sixth.
And I guess there's a
common factor of rho
everywhere that
we can cancel out.
So this is equal to rho squared
minus 3 x squared divided
by rho to the fifth.
OK.
So that's the
x-partial derivative
of the first component of F.
Now we need the
y-partial derivative
of the second component of F,
and the z-partial derivative
of the third component of
F. But if you go and look
back at what the
formula for F was,
you see that this is a very,
very symmetric formula.
So in order to get from
the first component
to the second component,
we just change
x to y, and to get from the
second component to the third,
we just change y to z,
because of course rho
treats x, y, and z the same.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means that
the partial derivatives
are easy to compute.
Having computed this
x-partial derivative,
we also get that
partial over partial y
of the second component--
which is y over rho cubed--
is equal to rho squared
minus 3 y squared, over rho
to the fifth.
And the last one we get, partial
over partial z of z over rho
cubed is equal to rho
squared minus-- I'm
getting a little
cramped here-- 3 z
squared, over rho to the fifth.
And so adding these
up, we get that div F
is equal to the sum
of those three things.
So let's see what we've got.
We've got a 3-- so
the denominators
are all rho to the fifth.
And we've got 3
rho squared minus 3
x squared minus 3 y
squared minus 3 z squared.
So this is equal
to 3 rho squared
minus 3 x squared minus 3 y
squared minus 3 z squared, all
over rho to the fifth.
But of course, rho
squared is x squared
plus y squared plus z squared,
so this numerator is just 0.
So this is equal to 0.
OK.
Which is what we
thought it should be.
All right.
Good.
So that's part a.
We just computed the
partial derivatives of F,
and then added them together
to get the divergence.
And we found that, in fact, yes,
the divergence was equal to 0.
Great.
So that's part a.
So let's go look
at what part b was.
Part b asks, can we
conclude that the flux
through the surface S is 0?
All right.
Now remember what the
divergence theorem says.
The divergence theorem
says that the flux
through a surface of a field
is equal to the triple integral
of the divergence of that
field over the interior,
provided the field is defined
and differentiable and nice,
or whatever, Everywhere inside.
OK?
But this field has a problem.
Almost everywhere, this
field is nicely behaved,
but at 0, we have
a real problem.
We're dividing by 0.
Right?
So this field is
not defined at 0.
So there's a single point in
the middle of this cube where
this field behaves badly.
And that means we can't
apply the divergence
theorem inside this cube.
So since we can't apply
the divergence theorem,
we aren't allowed to
conclude immediately
that the flux through
this surface is 0.
OK.
So the answer is no.
We can't conclude that
the flux through S
is 0, because one of the
hypotheses of the divergence
theorem isn't satisfied.
Namely, the field isn't defined
everywhere inside the surface.
OK.
So the answer to b is no.
OK, I'm just going
to write that.
But it's no because the
hypotheses aren't satisfied.
OK, so now let's look at part c.
So part c suggests, we can't
conclude that the flux is 0.
So we still want to
know what the flux is.
That's still an
interesting question,
so part c suggests,
maybe you can still
use the divergence
theorem-- well,
now we're calling it
extended Gauss's theorem--
to compute what this flux is.
So let's think about
how we could do that.
So remember what extended
Gauss's theorem says?
Or extended divergence theorem.
I'm going to try and just say
Gauss's theorem from now on,
so I stop having to say both.
But I mean both.
I mean, they're the
same theorem, right?
OK.
So Gauss's theorem says, when
you have a surface bounding
a region, the flux
through the surface
is equal to the triple integral
of divergence over the region,
provided everything is
well-defined and nice.
Extended Gauss's
theorem says, this
is still true if your region
has more than one boundary.
So for example, if your
region is a hollow something--
so if it's a
spherical shell that
has an outside sphere and an
inside sphere-- then extended
Gauss' theorem says, OK,
so you do the same thing.
You take the triple
integral of the divergence
over the solid region.
And then you take the
flux, but you add up
the flux over all of
the boundary pieces.
So you add up the flux over
the outside boundary surface,
and also, if there is one,
through any other boundary
surface.
OK?
And those two things are equal.
So the total flux through
all of the boundary surface
is equal to the
integral of divergence
over the whole region
bounded by those surfaces.
So how are we going to use this?
We're trying to compute
the flux through a surface.
OK, but we don't want to
compute a double integral
if we can avoid it.
We don't want to compute
the surface integral.
So what we'd like
to do is we'd like
to find a convenient
region over which
to compute this integral,
to put us in a situation
where we can apply
extended Gauss's theorem.
We can't use just the
inside of the cube,
so we want some other region.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to walk over here,
and we're going
to do-- there are
many possible things you could
do, but this is a nice one.
All right.
One thing you could do is
you could take a big sphere.
Take a big sphere.
So we've got our cube here.
This is the point (2, 2,
2), and this is the point
2, 2, minus 2, and so on.
So we've taken a big
sphere of radius R--
for some big R-- that
contains our surface
S that we're interested in, that
completely contains the cube.
OK?
So why have we done that?
Well, extended Gauss's theorem--
OK, so what does
extended Gauss' theorem
say for the region between
the sphere and this cube.
All right.
So our cube is named S.
Let's call our sphere
S_2, because why not?
OK.
And let's call the solid region
between them, between the cube
and sphere-- just
for convenience,
let's give it a name--
so, I don't know,
we often call solid regions
D, so let's call it D.
So it's this spherical region,
but it has a cubical hole
in the middle of it.
OK.
So what does extended
Gauss's theorem say?
So extended Gauss's theorem
says that the triple integral
over D of the
divergence of F dV is
equal to the sum of the fluxes
through each of the surfaces.
But for this, we want the
flux out of the solid region.
So for the sphere, the flux
out of the inside of the sphere
is the flux out of the sphere.
So that's integral over S_2
of F dot n, d surface area.
But for the cube, the
flux out of this region
is the flux into the cube.
Right?
Out here, you're living in
a region outside the cube,
so when you leave that region,
you're going into the cube.
So this is the negative of
the flux that we really want.
So this is minus the flux
through the cube of F dot n,
with respect to surface area.
So remember, the signs
here are different,
because I'm taking this normal
to be the outward pointing
normal to both surfaces.
The normal that points
away from the origin.
But the normal pointing away
from the origin on the cube
is the normal that points
into the solid region instead
of the normal that points
out of the solid region.
So that's why this
minus is here.
OK.
Whew.
All right, so what
does this mean?
Well, we've already
computed, in part
a, that the divergence--
so first of all,
F is well-defined
everywhere in this region
D. The only place F was
badly behaved was the origin.
And this region
doesn't contain it,
which is why this trick works.
So we've already computed
that the divergence of F
is 0 everywhere.
It's defined, so
it's 0 on all of D,
and so this triple
integral is just 0.
So if this triple
integral is 0, that
means we can just add
the thing that we're
interested in to
both sides, and we
get that the surface
integral over the cube of F
dot n, with respect
to surface area,
is equal to the surface integral
over the sphere of F dot n,
with respect to surface area.
OK.
So we've converted this original
integral-- our flux integral
that we're interested
in-- and we
found that it's equal
to this separate flux
integral over a
different surface.
This time over a big sphere.
OK, so that's nice.
Why do we want to do that?
Well, we want to
do that because F
is a really nicely behaved
field with respect to a sphere.
F is a radial field.
So F dot n is really
easy to understand.
F dot
n is just-- well, n is a unit
normal and F is a radial field.
So on a sphere, the
normal is radial, right?
It's parallel to
the position vector.
And F is radial.
So they're both pointing in
exactly the same direction.
So when you take
that dot product,
n is the unit vector in
the same direction as F,
so when you dot that with F, you
just get the length of F. OK,
so what does that mean?
That means over
here, this integrand
is really easy to understand.
OK?
This integrand F
dot n on the sphere
is just equal to the
length of the vector F.
Now what is the length
of the vector F?
Well, we know what F is.
It's x over rho cubed i hat,
plus y over rho cubed j hat,
plus z over rho cubed k hat.
So OK, so you compute the
length of that vector,
and what do you get?
Well, it's exactly
1 over rho squared.
OK.
But we said that
this is a sphere.
I guess I didn't write it down.
Let me write it down right here.
This is a sphere whose radius
is big R. It doesn't really
matter very much
what R we choose,
we just want it to be
big enough so that it
contains the whole cube.
If you said this a
sphere of radius 10,
that would completely
do the trick.
That would be totally fine.
OK, so the radius of
the sphere is big R,
so the length of the field,
we said, back over here,
is 1 over R squared.
The length of the vector F.
So this flux integral then,
is the integral over the
sphere S_2 of a constant.
So it's the integral over the
sphere of 1 over R squared dS.
But when you
integrate a constant
over a surface, what you get
is just that constant times
the surface area.
Well, what's the surface area?
This is a sphere.
It's easy to understand
its surface area.
Its surface area
is 4 pi R squared.
Right?
So this is equal to
the surface area,
so that's 4 pi R squared, times
whatever that constant was.
So the constant was
1 over R squared.
And so the R squareds cancel.
Right?
This is why it
didn't matter what
R we chose, because
they're just going
to cancel at the end, anyhow.
OK, so those cancel, and
we're left with 4*pi.
So let's just quickly recap
what we did in this part c.
We're looking to compute
the flux over the cube.
But it's a kind of unpleasant
integral we'd have to compute,
to total up the fluxes over
these various different faces
and so on.
So instead, we had
this clever idea
that we'll apply the divergence
theorem to replace the cube
with a more congenial surface.
So the surface we
choose, because this
is a nice radial vector
field-- that's our main hint.
Because there was a rho involved
in the problem, if you will.
So the surface that we
choose is some big sphere.
And then we apply the
extended Gauss's theorem
to the solid region between
the cube and the sphere.
Outside the cube, but
inside the sphere.
So because the divergence
of the field is 0,
the extended Gauss's
theorem tells us
that the two fluxes--
the flux out of the cube
and the flux out of the
sphere-- are actually
equal to each other.
But since the fluxes are
actually equal to each other,
in order to compute the
flux out of the cube,
it's enough to compute the
flux out of the sphere.
OK.
But computing the
flux out of the sphere
is relatively easy,
because on the sphere,
the integrand F dot
n is just a constant.
And so then we're integrating
a constant over the surface
of a sphere, and that just
gives us the surface area
of the sphere times
that constant,
which is 4 pi R squared times 1
over R squared, which is 4*pi.
So the flux out of the cube
then is also equal to 4*pi.
I'll stop there.